But if it was on medium,
if someone said like,
look at these dummies with their terrible fucking recipes,
it would still be almost as interesting.
But it's flavored by you're allowed to mock them because it should have.
But,
but it's,
it's almost like they're uneducated.
You know,
vox ran an article claiming that people who hold alt right views are like 11
million or some huge number and that's just like,
it's absurd.
That's not 11 million American.
Well,
you defined outright as being some sort of a white supremacist.
I will quote the associated,
okay.
Associated Press.
The AAP guidelines are that alt-right means white nationalist,
a desire.
Can I ask you this?
Who had to find that?
How does it,
why are they,
because Richard Spencer is the man who popularized the term.
Yeah.
So he,
he's not the one who coined it,
but he popularized it and he is a white nationalist.
Right.
So I mean,
you know,
if you want to be a part of his movement,
there are certain things that are attached to it.
And uh,
other,
other alt right people have written huge things about what it is.
So the AP said,
these are our guidelines and I'll,
I'll defer to the Associated Press.
I have a lot of respect for them.
There you go.
You know,
so if,
if there's a news organizations,
there was a Willamette weekly.
This is,
this is,
it's,
it.
Got It man.
I just really,
I,
I worked for vice,
I was actually,
uh,
I'm one of the key reasons vice news exists and I look back on it now.
It makes me kind of sad how they've written some of these,
most of these such ridiculous articles.
I'm really proud of a lot of stuff they've done.
But I,
I quit.
I quit when I got an offer from fusion and fusion is,
it was an ABC,
Univision joint venture.
When I,
when I started there,
they said,
we won't be partisan.
For some reason they decided to go far left and start pushing,
you know,
a lot of things that I thought were wrong.
They,
uh,
told me to in effect lie right.
So the,
the,
the thing I'm bring up is I just have such disdain for these,
these news organizations and how they use definitions that suit their needs to
get the clicks.
They want your altar right today,
you're not outright tomorrows.
Yeah.
Right.
The,
the,
the click thing is an issue.
An issue.
Right.
Um,
how much of an issue is that journalists are essentially fighting for their
lives because newspaper is almost dead.
Yeah.
It's online.
Publications are trying,
they're trying to get subscriptions.
Like I subscribe to several different news online public aid that used to be
newspapers,
but the last time I picked up an actual newspaper,
it's so much so that I felt like I had a joke about reading something in the
paper and uh,
like turning the page.
I almost felt like I'm a liar for doing a joke about turning the page of a
paper.
I don't remember the last time I fucking did that.
Everything I've read is either on a tablet or on a laptop or
do you know,
do you know what the Gal Man Amnesia effect is?
No.
When you're an expert in MMA,
you're like,
one of the foremost experts.
Have you ever read a news article about MMA that was so wrong?
Okay,
so that same newspaper,
you're reading it,
you see that store and you laugh how wrong it could be.
You turn the page and there's a story about Syria and you go,
I didn't know that.
Why would you forget how wrong they were?
But the reason I bring this up is the analogy is that you turn the page.
Yeah,
nobody does it.
You Click the link.